Punch biopsy of husbands, center cheek showed squamous cell carcinoma.
What treatments can he have done for the cancer of his cheek and the cancer cells that
have traveled to other parts of his body from the biopsy?
Her that moles surgery or radiation and chemo won't kill the cancer stem cells and carcinoma
will come back with a vengeance to that same spot of his face.
Well first I want to call up your heart but don't believe everything you hear because
those things can happen so let's explain this a little bit.
So a tumor on a person's face was tested, again I'm just reading these questions as to
how to look at these.
Squamous cell carcinoma have several different types of cancer, skin cancer.
The most common three is melanoma which is the most serious, squamous cell carcinoma which
can be equally serious and then basal cell which typically is not serious.
So basal cell carcinoma I have no problem with the person excise those tumors if they
want to even though I think it will be wise to try some topical things because you can
use a curcumin cream, you can use different essential oils on basal cell tumors and you
can have pretty good effects and then you don't have any scars from excising those tumors.
Squamous cell carcinoma is much more serious, typically with squamous cell and with melanoma
they're going to do a surgery called a mose surgery.
What a mose surgery is is they take out everything that they can see visually.
They'll understand cells are small, you can't see them, right?
You're seeing masses of cells, that's what you're seeing.
So even when a surgeon goes in and removes a mass, let's say it's a six centimeter mass
in the liver, they can only get what they see that they take out a little bit more tissue so
that they're hoping to get what is called a clear margin.
That's what a mose surgery is, typically we're talking about skin cancer removal is that
they're removing it deeper than what they could see that they immediately send that to pathology.
That's examined.
If it gets I think it's three centimeters of clear margins, then they call it good.
If they're like three centimeters of clear margin, they're going to go a little deeper,
look at pathology results, oh it's still not getting clear margins of going a little deeper.
That's what's called a mose surgery.
That's typically done on a squamous cell or melanoma, the phasal cell I think they just go
visually, but positives and negatives in that, the positives are that you're
devalcated a cancer, so whatever you're surgically removing a cancer, whether it be a breast cancer,
you're removing a lump, so that's called a lumpectomy or you go to a mastectomy, you're doing a,
you're removing the majority of visual mass.
So the positive thing is that if you're going to do other things, whether it's going after
removing the mass or the devalcated of the cancer, if you're going to do other things,
then you reduce the load on your immune system.
So if you think of it, if that my immune system, I'm going to try to boost my immune system to
try to kill cancer and I have this mass, whether it be a one centimeter mass that's maybe
two to three millimeters deep in a skin cancer, or it be a one centimeter round mass in a breast,
there are two centimeters round mass in my liver.
Debalcated a cancer is the term that we give that you're going in there and surgically removing
everything that you possibly can. So the idea is just to remove everything, it's to remove
what you, you're just trying to use your best common sense possible. So you remove what is visual
and by removing that as much active cancer that you can find, the positive is that you remove
the burden of your immune system to have to destroy that. So then you could work on
stimulating your immune system to clean up any other cancer cells that you have. So like this
person alluded to what could I do to help with the cancer cells that have traveled to other parts
of the body from the biopsy. So cancer cells that that leaves an original primary tumor and travel
elsewhere in the body are called circulating tumor cells. So circulating tumor cells are
are cancerous in the aspect of, they're not healthy cells, meaning with a healthy functioning mitochondria
and a healthy functioning nucleus, they're damaged nuclei in the cell, they're they're traveling to
other parts of your body, hoping to, like I always say, set up home and raise a family someplace else.
That's what their purpose is. What cancer cells, what differentiates cancer cells from,
from non-cancer cells is cancer cells, something got inside the cell, something got inside the cell,
at some point in time it damaged the nucleus, so now it's in a state of rapid replication.
Now when cancer cells are at a state of rapid replication, they're replicated unhealthy cells that are
also have that damaged nucleus in a rapidly replicating. So when you see a cancer that is
one centimeter large, that's millions and millions and millions and millions and millions of cells.
So there's going to be cells that are given along before you're even diagnosed with cancer.
If you just go in for a mammogram and you find this little spot, it's really little spot. So
we want to do an ultrasound and maybe do a needle biopsy of this spot. Well, long before you do the
biopsy, and long before this person did the biopsy of the squamous cell carcinoma on their face,
they already gave off cancer, that cancer has already given off thousands and thousands, maybe
millions of circulating tumor cells that are traveling throughout the body trying to grow somewhere else.
Now what's keeping that at bay is your immune system. So that's what's keeping circulating
tumor cells at bay from setting up another place and growing it again. If it does that, that's called
metastasis. Now is there a risk this person alluded to? What do I do to keep that at bay
from other parts of the body from the biopsy? So that phrase from the biopsy could say, well that's
conspiratorial, there's no way cancer biopsies cause an increase risk of metastasis. But actually,
there is documentation that does show that that does happen. There's a couple articles that were
written a few years ago and the ones that I looked at were on breast cancer biopsies. And it does
increase the risk of metastasis. But I will say skin cancer biopsies,
when your biopsy, the center, a punch biopsy of the center of the tumor, your risk of
increasing circulating tumor cells from the biopsy is much smaller than what was documented as a
needle biopsy, possible complications from breast cancer. Because you think of it, you're sticking
a needle into the breast. I didn't know how deep that tumor is. You're going in there,
exercising some cells through the needle, but then you're pulling the needle through that breast
tissue. The closer the tumor is to the surface, the less risk you have of spreading cancer
throughout the rest of the breast. That's your pulling that needle back out through.
So the deeper the tumor is, the greater risk you have of increasing
the spread of the cancer. So with a skin cancer, obviously, you're not spreading it through any
tissue. That is not cancerous. So I don't think that I would be worried about
the circulating tumor cells from the biopsy. However, that being said, what I said previously,
by the time you have, the time you have recognized that something is wrong and you have to go
to get a check. Your body is already given out of tons of circulated tumor cells.
From a nutritional standpoint, no, they don't do anything for circulating tumor cells.
From a functional standpoint, you can actually measure circulated tumor cells, but it's only
going to measure the circulated tumor cells in the blood. It's not going to measure circulated
tumor cells that have already settled somewhere in the tissue. So I don't even particularly like
that test because it could give you false hope that all my circulated tumor cells are zero. So
yeah, I didn't clear that doesn't actually mean that. However, so from a functional,
nutritional standpoint, what do you do for circulated tumor cells? Probably the number one thing that
you would do for circulated tumor cells is modified citrus pectin. So there's a product called
Pectisol C. It's a modified citrus pectin. I'll just get something that's this citrus pectin.
Certainly don't get something that's this pectin. It's modified citrus pectin. Pectisol C. I write
about it in my book Stop Fighting Kids or two, and you could look at it on our store. I probably have
multiple articles on our blog on modified citrus pectin. So look that up.
That would it be the way I would actually treat the swallow cell, but it would help
with circulated tumor cells. And that was your question. So as far as treating the swallow cell
in our clinic, we get a cheek swab, we test for what we think is the cause, how to deal with that,
we test for what we think is going to be the best attack of the cancer. And plus I would definitely
consider getting it right. I mean, the swallow cell could be as dangerous as melanoma. So it's not
something to play around with. You want to get at it as fast as you can. So in this case, I would
highly suggest you go on our website, schedule a case review with me, and you can discuss